housed gum rows my name's Peter Pan and
welcome to the Walking Dead Season 2
finally it's here it's time to save Clem
again we have been waiting for this game
for quite a while now Bros and the first
one was just it was probably the game on
the air for me at least and we'll this
game live up to the first one who knows
and we're gonna have to find that out I
do want to warn for spoilers if you feel
like you want to play this yourself I'm
gonna leave a link to it in the
description and you can go ahead and do
that what's cool about the game is that
it it's tailored around your own
decision so you get a different story
each time so it should be cool either
way I don't want to talk too much let's
just begin so for those of you who don't
know the game is divided into usually 5
episodes yep 5 of them and they're
released usually with one or a little
more than a month in between all of them
so now we're gonna start with episode 1
and I'm probably gonna keep this going
as a daily series because the game is
just too awesome not to oh man I
remember that I remember that to import
season 1 sakes isn't 2 so my choices
from season 1 is going to be in season 2
that's awesome previously oh hell yeah
ah what's your name I'm climbing 9
who've been all by signing this oh [ __ ]
I know who you are and I know you're a
killer this is not how the world works
now we are those bad people dead I hope
you know what you're doing with her my
god Molly said Crawford is the only
place left in Savannah that still has
people and it must be where my mom and
dad her okay
don't come but you have to promise to
stay quiet Clementine
Clementine oh yeah oh I know how to be a
dad you know that [ __ ] I she wouldn't
be exposed to what she has been with you
we I saw my parents I know you could
leave me it's okay you can come with me
don't torture me with this again I care
it's okay
except I shot him but otherwise it was
all the same
are we gonna okay there she is look at
her look at that scare that's adorable a
lot
probably I mean obviously what do you
think only you can't be serious
I am we are not doing that so she didn't
find them in the end cuz oh it's just a
place for fun
what's wrong with Oh me yes hey we're
not calling our baby or Meade one of you
is enough Clementine a little help here
whoa she's really frightening not this
second
no owe me junior no what if it's a girl
it has a ring to it
what if it's a girl then we named her
krysta but I'm Krista I don't want to
call her krysta that's just confusing so
name her Genevieve I don't care how can
you not care it's good to be back you're
not taking this seriously I take
everything seriously especially the low
meets future keep talking and you'll be
sleeping in the ring tonight remember
that time in Barstow Vegas weekend
why not get cleaned up at the girls room
clamp I hope the sink works in there I
wouldn't count on it just be careful and
make sure to keep track of your things
we'll be right next door oh [ __ ] you I'm
adorable but I guess you can't look out
for yourself that is
oh you clam make sure the bathroom is
safe how that gun looks way too big for
her don't jump skip me bro
that boy toilet gross
I don't be mean to him where's your
mater climbing clue what's that Oh what
I thought it was a rat Calot why you can
poop on that I think it's fine all right
well this looks okay good
no one's here dumb scare guess it's safe
to get cleaned up
yeah it looks like you went through a
tough time plan geez
she has a cute little bag
that's all better not better yeah
no I thought that water was gonna fall
out don't like this but I think it
felling this one right no it's fun yeah
you are very hygienic
yeah stop copying me Clem
who's that
Oh her gun was right there
she's gonna take the gun
oh not now toilet lid not now toilet lid
oh that's creepy I see you get out of
there you're not fooling me
that's my canal now that's my gun
smile now give it back why should I get
out here
she's little girl come on you got
anything on you come on let's see I
ain't gonna ask him no oh yeah that's it
how'd you make it this long I'm serious
what else you got
that's it don't lie to me I'll cop
give me what you got I'm not screwing
around come on - stop stop
give me that hat no no where'd you get
it
why do you care I asked you a question
my dad gave it to me just give it to me
that cold-hearted [ __ ] junk junk junk
look at all this junk
[ __ ] [ __ ] and more [ __ ] why you ain't
got nothing good not like the last
people I got they had all kinds of this
[ __ ] dr. Suresh
you ain't got nothin good you're just a
little fish you gonna cry little fish
gay fish this your daddy put a close up
doc um no no no no we just got started
no no not Omid come on goddamn it
[ __ ] hell I didn't eat you I didn't
mean to I didn't mean Oh
come on I mean don't die on me
you owe me can you hear me homie
poor clam for everyone
I mean see that oh god damn it
gotta play with my feelings like that
hey I mean she'd have to take the safety
off of the [ __ ] guns it's not like
whoops that Oh 60-month late oh damn
she cheat puberty I guess I don't know
this is early never mind that
Crysta talk to me they look skinny all
the baby the baby
why are they out in the woods this will
never work
look at this it's pathetic the woods do
wet to burn
it's more smoke than flame
at this rate we'll be eating this for
breakfast okay I can okay I can wait
only do is wait for what you should be
doing this not me
tending a fire so you can cook and stay
warm it's something you have to be able
to do Clementine otherwise
and
we can't build a big fire at night it
attracts too much attention
it's too dangerous when we're out here
by ourselves we need to eat don't we we
can't survive without food
I'm freezing you think this is bad wait
till we get up the Wellington then talk
to me about cold if we make it all right
we're going to go well example hard
months ahead of us this rain will turn
to sleet then ice then snow it's a nice
versus not easy
what am i Welling it safe they're safer
than here because of the cold or so they
say oh yeah I just need to keep moving
north
the sont des amis gets slowed down by
the cold yeah ladies in the comic book I
think but still can be easy to survive
in the cold I don't want to be Miss Lee
I guess I miss Lee I'm sure you do now
I'm gonna go look for more would you
just keep the fire lit what happened to
the baby
we're on it I know a lot of times you
bros are like wait you have to go back
and save him or whatever but I'm I'm
pretty sure he dies anyway
like seriously that stop telling me to
go back I make if I make a decision I
gotta keep going with it and so just
want to point that out find the lighter
to relight the fire okay pour well
Clements being strong in all this
despite everything that's happened
no hahaha that's adorable
oh did everyone in that family die yeah
they did even her lighter is cute
God Dan yeah that fires not gonna last
for long
have fun he looks mighty high
Oh
press and hold the left mouse to flick
okay
that's some cool controls I guess
really not easy and clam it's gonna be
fine better but still not enough the
flames are too low
we've got license plate can we do
something with this bird
guess we I gotta look for stuff huh
scratches on the tree that's strange
yeah we got a piece of wood right there
laziest fighter ever this might burn I
think it's too wet No
let's burn the log
uh-oh
ah
she imagining this
I'm an idler
oh you should get the girl where's the
rest of your crew ha I'm by myself
[ __ ]
Lian cut the [ __ ] lady oh no it's just
me
come on guys it's not saying you expect
us to believe you're out here all alone
distract him
oh damn right No
why did you want a little girl anyway
get the [ __ ] over here now
[ __ ] how did he not see her come out
here girl I'm not [ __ ] around Oh
goddamn
that slide Oh God Debbie's nice pants
hey you want to find me oh yeah oh yeah
up by a girl [ __ ] Oh Shay
never clam [ __ ]
how dare you call it no no new
oh [ __ ]
for you [ __ ] kidding
come on clam Oh what happened oh he got
suck
oh god watch out
don't you dare get [ __ ] lamb I don't
want any [ __ ] bidding bull like Danny
oh nice they're gonna make out that's
beautiful
mommy's guilty' okay
ah
I was the hell
that's got to be cold how does a hat
stay that is probably the biggest
goddamn so intense I'm like alright
brothers I'm gonna have to end the first
one here my internet is really slow so
I'm what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
upload the second round right away so
leave a like if you enjoyed watching and
I'll try to get it up as soon as I can
hits the sky come bro today I see you
bros in the next one it's gonna be an
epic series stay awesome
you